foreign
good evening and welcome to
stratford-on-avon District Council
planning committee my name is councilor
Lewis Adam I'm your chairman for this
evening I'm going to go through some
Basics first and then we'll get into the
agenda first of all there's no fire
alarm planned for this evening so if it
does go off please make your way out of
the building and into the car park
across the road by the pub where we'll
check your names off
please make sure that your phones are
off or turned to silent so they don't
disturb the flow of the meeting this is
a meeting in public and not a public
meeting which means that only those who
are registered to speak are permitted to
do so or call them forward at the
appropriate time and give further
instructions from there the meeting will
be broadcast and recorded on the website
and now I'll introduce the top table
from democratic Services we've got Kerry
Keller our legal officer this evening is
Sue Mullins our planning manager is Alex
cosnet and our planning officers in no
particular order are Malvina itzyak Ryan
O'Keefe Victoria Kempton Stuart McIver
and Emma Brooker
um Alice I believe you have a statement
prepared
I do thank you chairman my role is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members in their decision taking
thank you very much okay we move on to
the first item apologies for absence
we've apologies from councilors Eden
Pemberton passing him and Fleming with
councilor littlewood as substitute
thank you very much item number two
disclosures of interest I'm going to
start and say that for the first item
which is item number four application
23-01377
f-u-l oh wait no apologies wrong item um
item number three application 22
01653 full filled rear of napta
nurseries I was the previous Ward member
for Stockton and commented on the
application
um and as such
um I can't approach the committee with
an open mind so I'll be stepping down
from the table at that point and uh
councilor keithie will be chairing that
item
um members do we have any further
Declarations of Interest counselor
Harvey
uh just for the record I've made a
personal visit to the site in relation
to the application in Tomlin Road
Stockton in undertaking that site visit
I spoke to no one I discussed the
application with no one so I come with
an open mind
thank you very much any further
Declaration of Interest
no very good okay we'll move on to the
main agenda before we get to item number
three I'm going to move one forward
which is item number six
which is application
2300038 slash very these Farm Stratford
Road whitchurch we have no registered
speakers for that item so reason for it
coming to committee is now void
um I'm proposing that we delegate that
to officers
um I don't believe we need any vote on
the matter unless there's any dissent no
in which case
um that will be delegated
okay we now move then to item number
three and I'll vacate
this is now thank you councilor Adam
um I think I should put my name on that
oh did it ah okay thanks so much
right good evening everybody we're going
to
um look at item three which is uh
uh application
2201653 full it's a field rear of napton
nurseries tomlo Road Stockton
and uh
we have Malvina as the case officer so
if you'd like us to take us through this
application Malvina thank you very much
thank you chairman
um so the application site is located
um outside of napton on the hill
settlement immediately to the north of
Oxford Canal as denoted by the black dot
um on this plan
the application site comprises of
um part of an established industrial
estate and its existing access as well
as the field to the rear of it which is
crossed by the public footpath as
denoted by the green dust line on this
plan
planning permission is sold for erection
of an industrial building that would be
used by the existing business
um at The Wider side and the development
includes Associated parking and
Landscaping proposals
and on this plant the blue circle in the
top right corner and shows the location
of the closest neighboring dwelling
classical residential Barn
the next slide shows the proposed
elevations at the top you can see the
elevations that would be facing the yard
and at the bottom the elevations that
would be facing the field and the
neighboring site
the building would have 30 meters in
length over 15 meters in width and over
8 meters in height overall
so this Photograph shows the existing
site entrance
this Photograph shows tomlo Road and
existing vehicular access to the site
just there
and this Photograph shows the yard and
the existing units one two and three
the proposed building would be located
um behind the vegetation
so the next photograph shows uh Tumblr
Road and the kissing gate and the start
of the public footpath and Behind These
trees you can find the existing
application site I mean
um
the existing industrial estate
this Photograph shows the field
to behind the trees to the left hand
side is the existing yard and and behind
the trees to the right
[Music]
there is a Oxford canal
this photograph is taken approximately
in the middle of the field from the
public footpath and shows the existing
dwelling
just down
this Photograph shows the field
um looking
towards the
Southwest
um which means Tumblr road is Behind
These trees with the Canal Bridge over
there
this is the existing industrial site
behind those trees
and a photo taken from the top of the
field in the same direction the proposed
building would be located approximately
there
and you can see the roofs of the
existing industrial units as well
um
there was there were some updates on the
update sheet
um regarding uh plans being corrected
there was a slight discrepancy on the
plans which was corrected and it is
stated on the updates she that it does
not affect the current assessment
contained within the officer's report
and also
um that the county highways provided
further
clarification on the generated traffic
movements projected generated traffic
movements
um
chairman the recommendation is to Grant
planning permission for the development
subject to the conditions and nodes
detailed within the committee report
thank you
thank you very much Melvina
right
um
we have a number of people to speak
tonight
um
in fact one two three four five in total
um so I'll call you forward to speak at
the table here and you can press the
button and use the Micron I will need to
keep you fairly tight on time I don't
want to be brutal but I will give you a
30 second warning uh when you approach
your time that's so that we can get
through all the business on the agenda
tonight so first of all I'd like to call
counselor Richard Woodcock he's uh from
napton parish council do you like to
come forward councilor Woodcock thank
you very much and when you want to put
the microphone on and when you're ready
good evening
the first question that this planning
committee should be asking is how on
Earth was this problematic and
incongruous industrial estate ever
permitted to be built in this location
in open Countryside in the first place
it is in fact Beyond doubt that any new
application would not succeed in today's
planning world
second question should be why then would
the planning committee wish to
exacerbate the problems associated by
supporting the application and
permitting further expansion which will
inevitably increase noise and traffic
flow
the location and infrastructural
problems associated with this site are
clear to see surrounded by a myriad of
fragile Canal bridges on narrow country
lanes with threatened weight limits and
dangerous Junctions the only viable
option for Access would be an increase
of a predicted 40 articulated unit
Journeys per day straight through the
restricted Main Street of Stockton
Village and onto the a426 crossroads
which already has an appallingly high
accident rate
Neptune neighborhood development plan
was approved by referendum in May 2021
with a 57 turnout I suggest to the
committee that the proposal is in breach
of the following neighborhood
development plan policy requirements
in policy 4A it is not a development on
an appropriate scale to its location and
setting
in policy 4B it is not acceptable on the
living conditions of the occupiers of
any affected property
policy 4D and policy 9.1 it does
compromise the specially protected views
identified in the neighborhood
development plan
in policy 4f it does not protect and
enhance public rights of way and
encourage the use of existing network of
public footpaths screen lanes and tracks
to enable access by foot around the
village
in policy 5B it does not minimize noise
to protect the Tranquility of the area
in policy 7c it does not provide
external spaces which allow Visual and
physical access that encourage links
from the village to the canal Network
in policy 7h it does not provide and if
necessary upgrade pedestrian access to
maintain the role of the canal as a
green pedestrian link
and policy 7i
it does not promote understanding of the
canal heritage
30 seconds this application is contrary
to the eight neighborhood development
policy wordings which I have just lifted
and it is difficult to see how this
application could be permitted
furthermore although a footpath
diversion has been submitted to
accommodate the expansion It Is by no
means certain that it will succeed
in the interests of preventing further
environmental damage and in localism in
planning making decisions I asked the
committee to refuse this application
thank you very much that's a spot on
time as well thank you very much
um councilor Woodcock members do you
have any questions for councilor
Woodcock please
yes councilor Harvey
[Music]
the information we've been presented
with is that there
are highways
County Council figures suggest that
there would be 10 movements by hdvs per
day five in and five out how would you
square those two sets of numbers that's
a very good question because the notes
provided to this committee tonight quote
40 units per day
in the notes on the on the agenda for
tonight
and the report from the planning officer
councilor Harvey
I'll leave it there thank you
members anybody else a question for
councilor Woodcock I I have one myself
Council Woodcock let's just say I'm
hopeful that somebody will check those
figures because they're on your own
notes tonight for this meeting yes thank
you for that Council I'm sure that'll
come up in um questions for the case
officer Council Woodcock a quick
question from me
um I noted when I was reading the
objection from the parish council that
you claimed no details have been
submitted in respect of the impact of
noise on the development and I wanted to
ask you whether or not you'd since seen
the LF Acoustics report dated June 2022
which did Cover noise assessment no I
haven't seen that okay thanks very much
councilor Woodcock thank you very much
indeed for your time thank you
okay
um our second speaker is Emma Barnes
who's a resident on Tom Lowe road if
you'd like to come up Emma thank you and
uh that's three minutes for you as well
and when you're ready
um press the press the right hand side
on the little that's it super over to
you thank you
take to access the industry industry
State the industrial estate is situated
at the napton end of tomlo Road there's
a three-ton limited humpback bridge on
tomlo road at the napton end which is
Impossible by hgvs hdvs will have to be
routed through Stockton Village down
tomlo Road via Stockton Crossroads that
are a notorious accident hotspot next
page please
Stockton is a rural village with narrow
already congested Country Roads next
page please
any incremental HGB is trying to pass
through this rural Village cause case
safety concerns for the local for the
locals next page please
Tom Lowe road is an unclassified narrow
Country Lane it is continually being
patched up due to erosion and subsidence
caused by existing usage next page
please
and the next page
Tom Lowe Road highlighted in red is used
by residents and others for walking
cycling and horse riding as it joins a
number of footpaths and Bridal ways
highlighted in yellow together any
expansion of industrial usage into rural
areas reduces the quieter roads that
vulnerable Road users are able to use at
reduced risk next page please
this shows the location of the current
industrial estate and proximity to
Bridge Nursery Christine's home and
Business established in a tranquil rural
location across the center of the
industrial estate expansion is a
well-used public footpath next page
please
the red square is an approximation of
the expansion the scaling dimensions of
buildings are not aligned on the plan so
it's difficult to be accurate and
questions whether the quest at the
building or scaling is correct is it a
30 meter building or a 34 meter building
it is acknowledged that there will be
increased noise at Bridge Nursery
environmental health recommend directing
noise mitigating fencing however the
proximity to the residential home is
unconfirmed due to the scaling stroke
building dimensional misalignment so the
effectiveness of the fencing is
questionable next page please
the additional additional industrial
building will displace a significant
amount of rain water per year onto
already very low lying poor drain in
clay Land Bridge Nursery already
struggles to manage rainwater
displacement what is the plan to manage
rainwater drainage for the new unit and
prevent impacting their neighbors as
there's nothing defined
in conclusion there are over 40
objections to this application from
residents napton and Stockton Parish
councils the district councilor and we
have support from Jeremy Wright for the
issues raised
the impact to the local rural
communities due to the increase in hgbs
to the expanded site is undeniable the
size and exact location of the
application is unclear due to the
anomalies between scaling and dimensions
on the plans therefore the noise impact
to Bridge nursery and Rural Outlook is
also unquantifiable nor is the
effectiveness of the noise mitigation
requirements success suggested by
environmental health this application
was due to be decided in September 22 is
causing ongoing stress anxiety for
Christine and her family our request is
to reject this application or at least
defer it to enable the open points to be
fully investigated
well thank you very much Emma
um
that's super thank you very much for
that
um are there any questions from members
for um Emma
yes councilor Harvey
Miss Barnes are you
elucidate please I'd like to if possible
I'd like to know a number of accidents
frequency of accidents seriousness of
accidents
no I don't have that data it is a hot
spot at the top of napton here of
Stockton Road where there is
a regular accident but I can't give you
details of when in severity
councilor Harvey
thank you very much
okay so um
our next two speakers are uh applicants
or and supporters it's a John Clark and
Anthony Pugh I understand
um both speaking so you've got three
minutes each or six minutes between the
two of you I guess uh how are you going
to play this
three minutes each okay I'll keep an
answer for the time so who's on first
uh right hand side
I'll be on first John Clark thank you
John okay so when you're ready John
members thank you for this opportunity
to speak this evening
I'm the applicants town planning
consultant and alongside me is Tony Pugh
who's the applicants architect
I don't want to repeat anything which
has already been said I do wish to
highlight the following points to factor
into your consideration
first of all as confirmed by your
officers the principle of the
development are calls with operative
development and plan policies namely
core strategy policy cs22 which supports
the principle of the expansion of
businesses in their existing locations
core strategy policy as10 Criterion n
which supports the extension of a
business in its established location
policy 4 of the natton on the Hill
Neighborhood development plan which is
supportive of business and economic
development
and policy 10 of the neighborhood
development plan which support
development outside of the built-up area
of settlements where it is in line with
national and local planning policies
turning to site-specific considerations
it is significant that there is not a
single objection to the proposal from
any of your technical consultees
the applicant has provided all required
technical information through the course
of the application to demonstrate that
the proposal is acceptable in
site-specific planning terms
I'll now pass you on to Tony for the
second part
okay John
uh I'm Tony Pugh 80 Architects with the
architects who designed the the building
and we work on behalf of trend Gray
Construction Limited
Dragon construction are the primary
occupier of the site currently and a
local company established in 1985 and
operated from Coventry Bridge Meadow
since 1994.
the function of their business is
General construction Contracting both in
the immediate vicinity and within an
area of about a 25 mile radius
prior to 1994 Coventry Bridge Meadow was
used solely as just plant and material
storage and in 1994 there were grounded
planning permission for an office and
Warehouse unit to accommodate their
expanding business
they currently have seven full-time
employees working from the offices with
another 25 site-based operatives
with the new development they will be
looking to increase the office numbers
by at least 50 percent providing more
opportunity for local people
the majority of their Workforce are
locally based and in addition to Trend
gray in addition to engrave provide
apprenticeship schemes enable young
people to experience and gain training
in the construction industry
in addition to train grade construction
there are currently three other
companies that operate from Coventry
Bridge Meadow
3D tooling strongman tools and
Warwickshire car and commercials Limited
these also employ a number of local
people and are established and thriving
independent businesses although they
share the same site with train great
construction to the contrary of an
assertion may have been comments from
objectives train grade construction have
no control over these businesses or
their premises
Tren gray is Keen to remain in napton
because it's established its roots there
and has a reputation in the area and is
Keen to utilize the pool of talent in
the local community
they've undertaken several projects
within the local Villages including the
building and subsequent extensions to
the primary school in napton work on the
village Sports Pavilion along with an
extension to the church and numerous
residential projects in the area
the location of the new unit will be
adjacent to their existing premises and
will allow Trend gray to remain on the
site which they have occupied for over
the last 30 years
it is their preferred locality and which
will benefit the local employees and
Associated local businesses and
Community therefore as recommended by
the offices I will ask members to look
favorably upon this application thank
you
thank you very much and we're within
your time
um members do we have any questions for
either John Clark or Tony Pugh please
councilor Parry
thank you Jan good evening gentlemen
um the previous speaker highlighted in
fact the past the previous two speakers
highlighted their concerns about hgv
movements to the site and back and I
note in the officer's report that there
would need to be submission approval of
a freight management routing strategy
um could you perhaps just add a little
bit more information you've obviously
thought carefully of the hgv movements
and also in the update sheet it does
mention Circa 40 vehicle movements per
day of which 10 hgv movements per day
would be five in and five out I just
like a little bit more clarity on the
hgv
movements and your plans for a freight
movement strategy thank you I think just
just to clarify I think there was a
confusion earlier where you asked if
there were 10 ACB movements in the
previous speaker
said there were 40 but the truth is
there are 40 traffic movements that the
highways have identified of which 10
were hgv I think that's
clarifies that situation as far as the
HEB routing is is concerned they they I
understand the our client is in
conversation with some traffic
Consultants who are now putting forward
together a strategy of how that would
pan out uh it it I know it has an effect
on all communities in any increase in
traffic will affect communities but of
course what we're looking at is
potentially about one traffic movement
per hour with an HGB so it's it doesn't
appear to be extensive but it needs to
be addressed to make sure that that is
run effectively so as I understand that
there is a traffic consultant that is uh
got that in hand and put forward a
strategy which I believe will be a
condition of the approval sorry John
okay thank you sir councilor Perry
councilor Harvey I have several
questions
to do with the traffic want to follow
that I don't one of the things that I
that I I did understand the 40 movements
and 10 lorries fine understood what I
haven't got a grip of is what that
thought is in relation to is that a five
percent increase is it a 20 increase is
it doubling I have no contact in which
to understand an additional 40 movements
whatever they are can you help me with
that
I haven't got the figures but my
understanding is it it equated to
something like a 15 increase in traffic
10 10 to 15 I think it was
that would affect the size
thank you
um
this is an application for a warehouse
uh one of the
uh
criteria by which uh it would support
this application would be a
demonstration that there is economic
benefit provided by granting the
application could you outline what you
think the economic benefits are and
could you as far as possible could you
quantify those benefits please
through you chair we'll come back to
specific figures in a moment but the
existing estate is established as a B1
B2 and B8 use estate B1 is now Class E
um so the planning Authority has
authorized
um commercial use of this site
within that in terms of
um
percentage in terms of employment I
think we quoted a potential 50 increase
in employees
yeah
um so President we have um seven
full-time employees so hopefully that
would be a 50 increase in the number of
employees but it's it's the knock-on
effect the local community in terms of
um taking on apprentices and
um undertaking work for the local
community
I think the principal benefit is really
that Trump Gray Construction are an
established business that have been very
successful they've grown over the years
and they're bursting at the seams in
effect that need to expand to allow them
to progress and gain further contracts
they are struggling with undercover
storage facilities so a lot of the
materials sadly have to be stored
outside at the moment and one of the
reasons for this Warehouse building
would be for the storage of of building
materials it's also we're in an era
where trying to get materials is is
difficult and therefore to actually be
able to store your own materials for
Sciences is incredibly useful
thing to do
Mr Harvey anymore final question
um
which relates to if I get my head into
gear
um yeah
one of the one of the requirements you
the organization might have gone through
in order to think about this application
is whether it could have moved to
alternative site
uh
thereby
making this application redundant can
you outline what considerations have
been considered uh in in moving to an
alternative so how practical is that and
what are the difficulties of doing so
and through you chair first of all um
with due respect I don't think that is a
relevant town planning question because
the the policy operative policies the
support for the expansion of a business
in its existing location so with due
respect I don't we will give you some
information but I don't I think that's
beyond a planning question but we will
give you some information about that
that question but the officers should be
able to confirm I don't think that's a
relevant planning question you confirm
that Alice please uh yes of course
through you chair
um as10n which is what we've been
quoting States an extension to a
business an established located will be
supported in principle particularly if
it would be unreasonable to expect the
business to relocate in order to expand
so I do think there is a relevance of
the question if you are able to provide
an answer I think it would assist thank
you
I I I can't be categorical about this
but my understanding is they have looked
for quite a period of time a alternative
premises but unsuccessfully but they are
very keen to stay within a very small
geographical area because they obviously
have their Roots there they are an
established business that have been
going for over 30 years and it's not
easy for any company just that
you know pack up and go and move
somewhere else
thank you councilor Harvey
happy with that
thank you uh members any other questions
oh I have a question myself
um just first of all in respect to the
traffic movement so I think some of the
confusion was caused by the acoustic
report
that quoted a number of hgv movements in
the yard which was something different
to the trics data that I looked at but
in response to the proposal to create a
joinery workshop within the warehouse
there have been some suggestions that
this might introduce immunity impacts on
neighbors because of noise
so could you tell me a little bit more
about the type of joinery work that
would be involved and how
frequent that would be would that be all
day long for example are you making
doors and windows or roof trusses could
you explain a little bit more about the
scale of that work please
my understanding is that uh
obviously Trend Gray Construction are
now a largest company and that they
Outsource a lot of the joinery work I
don't think they're looking to Outsource
doors or Windows but they are looking to
Outsource I think what they're looking
to bring in is is is putting together
kitchen units and and smaller items of
joinery that they could actually then do
in-house rather than rely on somebody
else doing that for them so it's not the
manufacturing of doors per se or
whatever but it could be the The Cutting
of of skirtings and length into certain
lengths and whatever else that they
could do undercover uh before taking it
to site
okay thanks so much did you want to add
something to that yes please Joe
um there are existing noise level
conditions and hours of operation
conditions on the side and those are
going to be repeated as recommended by
your officers so in terms of um the
applicant does not want to cause any
problem to any neighbor they thought
about it they've done the noise survey
we will comply with the noise conditions
proposed and the hours of operation so a
combination of those two will make sure
there's no disturbance to the immediate
neighbor okay thank you very much any
further questions around the table no in
which case thank you very much gentlemen
okay
um right moving on to our final speaker
it's um counselor Nigel Rock
um
the board member for Bishops itchington
Valley Compton and napton
good evening councilor Rock um you've
got five minutes when you're ready to go
over to you I think officers have got
some slides oh there they are
um
if we're ready I I hope I'm going to
stick strictly to the five minutes
chairman okay we've got slide one yes
thank you
um
as usual with committee items this is a
balance between policies on the one hand
to support a local construction business
to grow in a rural spot and on the other
hand those that balance against the
proposal
with respect I have formed a different
conclusion to the officers
in context this is a very rural area
with constricted access to Stockton
Village to the Northwest and narrow
roads which are bounded by humpback
bridges in all other directions
it's no surprise that napton Parish
Council has a humpback Bridge included
in their logo could have slide two
please
the nearest Canal Bridge to the site is
blind to Road users approaching from
napton
I'm surprised that County highways have
concluded that increased use of the site
entrance by large Vehicles is not
problematical
however I see that the reported accident
history confines itself to the actual
site turnout not to the bridge north
Stockton Crossroads where I know there
have been a number of accidents I could
probably give you a little bit more
information about that I could have
slide three please
this shows my own experience when
breasting the humpback to find a truck
delivering to the side incidentally this
truck is parked by the Turning area
forming the widened part of the road
which otherwise has a prevailing width
of only five meters that's slide four
please
this is the view of the bridge from the
side interest entrance and illustrates
how little an oncoming driver can see
all our agreed that this is development
in the open Countryside contrary to the
core strategy as-10
is it outweighed by other policies
this site has been a case of incremental
development
could have Slide Five please
I remember this site 30 years ago as
having only one small agricultural bar
as shown adjacent to the highway
it's changed to commercial was justified
as reuse of a redundant Farm building
various buildings and hard areas have
been added in successive steps and this
proposal would be the greatest increment
according to the Blue Line the whole
site in plumbing terms is in control of
the applicant but now has other
businesses on site
for commercial and historical reasons
those areas are said not actually to be
available to the applicant
an expansion into the open Countryside
is now necessary
I can't see evidence from any other
documents on the website the other
commercial sites nearby have been
considered I've got slide six please
uh that that marked is a very pleasant
walking circuit using sm-37 from the
village to the canal and the canal
Reservoir and then back along the canal
tow path
this foot path pass is so close that it
will have to be diverted
on page nine I fear the officer has a
lower opinion of the quality of the
landscape and does the napton
neighborhood development plan
this area and its Associated view from
napton Hillside is policy protected as
valuable in the labor development plan
specifically nominated in page 69 of
that plan as view one and marked with
the arrows as shown on the slide
potential noise nuisance to the close
closest dwelling has been an issue for
the application history
whilst environmental health officers
have not raised formal objection they
State there is a potential for
residential immune immunity to be
impacted detrimentally and recommend
conditions to limit the impact extra
internal noise insulation and a two
meter high acoustic fence
no extractor funds are to be permitted
are these practical effective and
enforceable conditions
can we guarantee that at all times a
storage and joinery business will be
able to carry on day-to-day activity
with the doors closed at all times and
we have no need for an extractor fan of
any type
will work stop during comings and goings
and deliveries
this is a large industrial building more
appropriate to an industrial estate such
as those currently available inside them
indeed they are under still under
construction there and they would be
more a suitable more more suitable
location for such a business
according to the applicant some of their
staff live inside them
whilst note in the suggestion of buffer
planting this is a in Congress
industrial building with noise barrier
fencing imposing bulk and perceived Mass
on Aurora landscape determined as
valuable in the NDP as 30 seconds
councilor Rob this is a fundamentally
unsustainable location with detriment to
Stockton Village to a private dwelling
and to the rural landscape
it is contrary to is-10 and the
expansion built in and upon open
Countryside is not outweighed by any
sequential tester exploring other
alternatives
I've found it's a difficult assessment
because I want to support local
businesses
but I do find I agree with the parish
council that the scheme does not conform
to the policies of the neighborhood
development plan which the parish
council has supplied the Clauses for one
by one thank you very much for listening
thank you very much councilor Rock
um members any questions for councilor
Rock please
uh
counselor sorry councilor littlewood
thank you chair
um
advise me Council Rock of the distance
between this proposed site and the
industrial site in southern please
uh
well you can see on that plan
uh see where it says you have said them
uh so I
that's Northfield Road just slightly
below that and that would be
three miles
I don't quote me today 100 meters crow
flies or is along the main road yeah
okay thank you thank you Council as well
thank you councilor Harvey
cancer Rock
um
you said you might be able to provide us
with some elucidating information
concerning accidents I wonder if you'd
like to take the opportunity please yes
I regrettably I I I it is regrettable
that you haven't got the accident data
um and I'm not going to provide you any
numbers which I'm sure you'll be
disappointed to know councilor Harvey
but I did have Stockton in my award for
eight years
um and uh
Stockton Crossroads
well I lost count of the number of
accidents there on I I witnessed two
accidents there myself
uh there was an accident there two days
ago uh it was
a tremendous issue when we had a quarry
uh consideration there uh like Bob
Stevens used to live there it it was a
continuous problem and it's been a
problem to us with traffic with buses
that turning around there however I
can't Supply the numbers and it's
unfortunate we haven't got the numbers
in the county appear to have confined
themselves to the accident history at
the uh actually at the turnout for the
site similarly with the humpback bridge
I'm aware of two serious accidents the
humpback bridge but uh
numerically I can't provide that
can't counselor Rock could I just say
that I think the the planning officer
has just told me that we do have some
further data for the area so we'll be
able to cover that in some questions the
case officer thank you chairman that's
helpful
councilor Harvey anything else
um members any other questions I have a
question for you counselor Rock if
that's okay you just mentioned that
there was some um some alternative
industrial units available in southam
they're available to lease as as I
understand although I noted that the the
size was significantly less than the
applicant is looking for for this one
unit itself have you done any further
investigations into properties that
might be available to buy within say
five or six miles radius
uh no I have not I'm aware they've been
during this as has been pointed out by
others this has been quite a
long-running application and and the
property Market comes and goes uh all
the ones I'm aware of I think are
available to lease so but that doesn't
mean to say there are no others okay all
right thanks so much for that
thank you very much
yes thank you Council Rock sorry yeah
you're dismissed
right members now we're moving into
questions of clarification for the case
officer so members have you got any
questions and if you'd like to indicate
I'll bring you in uh enter seraphin
thank you yeah hello my winner
um
on the update sheet it states that the
site plan is slightly larger than the
comparison the proposed floor plan have
you got any measurements or details on
that
thank you counselor
um so
um one of the
residents spotted an error on the plan
that it doesn't scale correctly the
distance between the proposed building
and the neighboring dwelling
um however after checking the plan the
plan was to scale and the scale bar was
correct however the footprint of the
proposed building was slightly larger in
comparison to the floor plans and
elevations which means that the distance
from the building is correct
um as stated in the report
um however obviously the footprint was
too large and I requested it to be
corrected and amended plans were
received to address it so the plants are
now the measurements of the building are
consistent across all the plants and the
distance Remains the Same as stated in
the report if that makes sense
yeah okay thank you happy with that
um councilor Parry
thank you chair
um
in a lot of
points raised about traffic movements
hgv numbers
and I wonder whether you may be able to
tell us whether highways actually have
visited the site in view of the number
of the issues and because of the hgv
um
Focus shall we to this new site and also
do you know
um this may be something that we need to
refer back to one of the earlier
speakers how many hgvs are visiting the
current site and are they using these
humpback Bridges and going through
Stockton currently because presumably
the size of the industrial unit there
must be some form of deliveries to the
existing business and going out so it
would just like a bit of clarification
on the impact the current
site has and therefore that will enable
us to put into perspective the new
figures for the proposed site if that
makes sense thank you
thank you counselor
um so
um regarding the highway Authority
visiting the site I'm not sure to be
honest if someone visited
um to make an assessment but
um
well
this application has been with the
council for a long time as well as the
previous applications so I understand
that
County highways had more done enough
time to Pro to you know thoroughly
assess this site
um in respect of the existing impacts
um from the existing development we
don't have this information as it does
not relate to the
um directly to the current proposal
we're only assessing the increasing
traffic not the
um but obviously the highways must have
you know taken into account the existing
side together with the proposed and on
that basis there was no objection
um in relation to the existing
um
traffic
using the common Bridges uh I do not
think personally that it would be
possible for a agv to pass through the
weak Bridge because it has a very low
limit so I think because of the location
of the camel bridges in in the area
um the traffic must use another
alternative route and
it would just damage the bridge it would
collapse so I don't think they could use
it
okay councilor Harvey
if I on that particular Point having
visited the summit my my impression
would be that long wheelbase hdvs
couldn't get over the bridge not because
of the weight issue but because of the
the steepness of it they they'd barely
out so to speak
um questions
um the transport statement that has been
submitted with this application makes
reference to
crashmap.co.uk as being a source of
information
um
I have looked at that and it indicates
that this the route that would have to
be taken with this application to be
approved from the site up Tumblr Road
Station Road up to the crossroads
it indicates no accidents along that
route at all the only accident uh point
of accident is the crossroads itself so
I'm at my question is
um what Reliance how accurate what what
credibility has the information that's
yielded on crashmap.co.uk
um so I know that the county highways
they have their own database
about the accidents and in their formal
response they provided that there were
no accidents near the site access since
the
I don't know
yes since like 1990
um and
also I requested further information
about the accidents
um in Stockton and the highway officer
provided that on napton road there were
um
four
accidents in total in the last five
years
so that's the data I have from the
highway officer
could you just clarify to members
um whether or not those involved hgvs
[Music]
so a two two accidents on napton road
are described
as cars and to to others are described
as vehicles
so I'm not sure about the two other
um accidents but two of them are just
cars
hey thank you for that councilor Harvey
can I press you on on the question of
context and numbers Mr Pugh gave the
when I asked the question can you
provide any contextual data he he
offered that the 40 movements would
equate to something of the order between
10 and 15 percent increase
um you could take a view on that one way
or the other can you provide any
information alternate information to
either substantiate that or not because
I think we Face the difficulty of being
faced on the one hand with evidence or
views from the from the statutory
consultee and other assertions from
members of the public
um no so I think marvena touched on
earlier that we can only assess the data
in respect of The Proposal now I
understand why you want to
have the context but unfortunately that
information hasn't been submitted and in
the absence of a insufficient reason
objection from County highways we don't
have any reason to ask for it at this
stage they're satisfied that the level
of information that has been submitted
is sufficient to determine that the that
they're content to raise no objection on
the basis if they're not being
unacceptable harm to highway safety
okay councilor Harvey could I just ask a
question in in respect of that following
up from councilor Harvey can we be clear
that the assessment of uh 40 movements a
day
as I understand it was 20 in and 20 out
and that that included cars and vans so
people getting to work and perhaps sales
people visiting and stuff like that as
well as the 10 hgvs
can you can you can you make sure that
we're clear on that that a large
proportion of the 40 seems to be like
vehicles
yes this this is correct based on the
highway Engineers response to my query
about
whether the number 40 is
um
counts round trips or just single trips
and the highway engineer confirmed that
it would be 20 trips in and 20 trips out
um which includes five
agvs in and five ATVs out
so this is what I received from from the
highway engineer and um
um
in my report I assumed that the number
40 relates to agvs when I assess the
impacts on the residential amenity in
Stockton
but now it appears that it will be less
agvs
um
trips generated as a result thank you
Melvina
um I have look at councilor Harvey last
question
um
are we entitled in coming to a
determination to make an assessment of
the degree to which the applicant has
sought alternative premises
we heard from Mr Pew that they had made
some efforts on the other hand we heard
from councilor rock that there were
alternative uh suitable well he didn't
quite say suitable he said there were
alternative premises available three
miles away in southern
or they're about are we entitled in
coming to A View to assess to make an
assessment of the degree to which uh
finding alternative premises has been
made or not
policy as-10 doesn't specifically
require any sort of sequential test to
be demonstrated however coming back to
the point which I made earlier
um is that as10n does talk about whether
it's unreasonable to expect the business
to relocate in order to expand so to my
eyes if we were identifying as an
example harm to landscape then I think
there'd be more justification for us to
say well the proposal is causing harm we
need you to demonstrate why the business
has to expand here and it can't relocate
so as to comply with as10n in this case
we don't consider that there's
unacceptable harm so because of that we
haven't
asked for information to justify what
they have done to identify other sites
that they could move to but what we have
done through the course of the
application is require the submission of
additional information to justify that
it is tread work tread gray that's going
to expand so that we can be sure that it
does comply with that Criterion under
as10n
that's how
thank you very much members any further
questions councilor littlewood
thank you chair
um just to go back sorry to go on about
the vehicle movements but um the numbers
that are presented here they are by
definition averages is that correct
during the working week
it's uh the way highways model things is
using tricks data
it gets very technical so I can't go
into detail beyond that but they rely on
a tricks database which holds a load of
data and that helps them to model what
movements are likely to require based on
the inputs put in yeah
my question really relates to the fact
that I'm aware that they they model it
but it doesn't really give you any idea
if there is a peak of movements at any
one point during the week and
um clearly
an operation of this sort can determine
when deliveries and
and orders going out take place and I
wonder if it's possible in order to
control that situation of peak movements
particularly of hgvs whether or not a
condition could be placed to make sure
that there is a maximum movement set of
movements is that possible
in the absence of a recommended
condition from County highways I think
we'd be on sticky ground the only thing
I would say is that environmental health
have recommended the attachment of a
condition restricting hours of operation
so they'd be between 7 30 and 5 30
Monday to Friday 9 30 to 1 pm Saturdays
with nothing on Sundays and bank
holidays so that will naturally limit
yeah that would include delivery so that
would obviously limit the the time of
um deliveries and movements to within
those areas highways and the transport
statements submitted with the
application as well as a response from
highways hasn't identified any concerns
in respect of peak hours
so in the absence of them expressing
concern I don't think I think like I say
with the honest Sticky Wicket to attach
a condition to restrict that
um because we haven't got any evidence
to say that it's required in order to
make the impacts of the development
acceptable
constantly let's look happy with that
yeah I'm happy with that answer but uh
it also occurs to me that uh a a freight
movement strategy was also required and
we haven't seen that there's no evidence
that that is in other than in progress
work in progress but that surely could
be part of a condition that is that not
more to do with the routing agreement
and the way in which the routing would
be advised or
um confirmed to drivers
uh yeah absolutely so that the freight
routing strategy is really to identify
the route and also the measures to be
put in place to encourage drivers things
like awareness
um education of drivers so they know
that the appropriate route to take again
I mean it could be we would consult with
County highways on that routing strategy
and if at that stage they consider that
they require information to be included
relating to Peak traffic then that could
be something they could ask for but I
can't guarantee at that stage that they
would because they haven't identified
that as a potential issue at this point
in time okay thank you councilor Perry
thank you final question from me I
wonder whether the case officer can
advise what weight we can give to the
made neighborhood development plan which
has got eight uh the parish
council highlighted eight aspects of
policies
um
that were not in favor of this
development during the presentation but
then also there were also other policies
in the MPD which were favoring expansion
of business and economic development
um
just some guidance
with the NDP being made it has full
weight as part of the development plan
if there's any conflicts between the NDP
and the course strategy the NDP would
take favor because that's the policy
document which has been adopted most or
made most recently
um as the parish council have identified
they consider there to be conflicts
officers don't
um so it's that interpretation of policy
and what's proposed that's obviously for
members to Grapple with this evening
thank you councilor Perry
um any further questions
I have one last question I just want to
point clarification on the footpath
diversion can you confirm there were no
objections to the diversion of the
footpath
um thank you counselor in terms of our
consulties I mean I know there were
neighbor objections okay
um I I so from from the consulties there
are no objections
um
if that answers your question that's
okay thank you thank you
so if we finished with um points of
clarification
um what I'd like to do is move into our
debate about this
um obviously many issues to consider
um a difficult balance to achieve given
the the traffic routing and the concerns
about hgvs coming through
um Stockton to the main road
who would like to offer to start the
debate or with their views please
it's a difficult one
somebody's going to pitch in in a second
I know Pete counselor Hunter thank you
very much yeah
um although I'm in favor of local
businesses in rural areas but not
large-scale Road narrones
people's concerns and the uh
Parish NDP
so
I think this this becomes an industrial
estate where it where it's probably more
suitable on an industrial estate and
save them
thank you
okay thank you for that
[Music]
anybody else like to pitch in
what are you waiting for me oh councilor
Barry
I wouldn't dream of taking your place
dirt I think it would be more than
appropriate for you and I'd be delighted
to to follow
okay thanks very much councilor Parry um
yeah just a tricky one
um my thoughts are that um the officers
clearly have found no material planning
reasons to object there's been no
statutory consultation subjecting I
think that being some concerns about the
traffic and that when I looked at this I
thought that was probably the principal
concern of people I'll come on to
neighbor impact in a minute but in terms
of traffic
um given that the evidence book before
us is telling us that there's a really
very limited number of age TVs and I'm
guessing probably quite a lot of traffic
coming through
um napton as it is
I'm just wondering if really we're
looking at
a significant
incremental impact or not and I'm not
sure that we are
10 h g v movements if I'm right five in
five out
during the course of the day
is is not really very significant in my
mind
um the
information that we have
on the accident statistics as well
suggests that although anecdotal
information from Neighbors and objectors
is that there have been a lot of
accidents it's an accident black spot
hotspot whatever you want to call it
the accident statistics provided to us
don't bear that out
and we've really got to make decisions
based upon evidence
the neighbor immunity
is obviously of some concern in respect
of the neighbors I read the objections
being overshadowed
loss of light
but in fact the the officers didn't
consider that and this is significant
separation between the nearest
residential property and the edge of the
building is about 40 meters the
building's only eight meters high
there is a significant buffer zone
so I'm I'm struggling to see
um quite where the objection is there I
do understand that there may be noise
impacts because you're moving in
industrial unit closer to that single
residential property and there's going
to be some joinery but we've heard from
the applicants that that joinery
business is sounds pretty small scale to
me kitchens skirting boards and things
like that it's not a major Timber
processing yard and the work will be
done inside
so um
all things on balance I appreciate that
the traffic Route is probably not ideal
but then it's already servicing that
industrial site
with no no controls that I'm aware of so
presumably vehicles are coming in out of
the existing site
so incrementally I'm not sure that we've
got a reason to refuse and go back to
what I said at the beginning the the
statutory consulties aren't offering
reasons for refusal either
so whilst I uh appreciate the impact
that this might have on uh you know that
area and the intensification of
industrial use it does provide some
additional jobs the applicant is saying
the business could to take apprentices
it will create some additional
employment in that area I think that's a
very good thing
I think on balance I'm coming around to
thinking that it would be difficult to
find a reason
to go against the recommendations of the
officer
so that's my position
who would like to follow me counselor
Barry
thank you chair
um I mean in a nutshell we have no
objection from WCC highways
um so I totally agree with you on that
we have as10 supporting the expansion of
existing businesses albeit in the
countryside we have call strategy cs22
which supports the expansion of
businesses whilst we do have a
neighborhood development plan within the
MPD it is in support of local businesses
and economic development and therefore
we've we've gone round and round in
houses about the hgv and the traffic
movements in my mind there are no
material planning reasons to refuse this
application chair
thank you councilor Perry is that a
proposal
can you confirm I thought you were going
to propose chair
okay thank you councilor Perry
um councilor Harvey
this is uh head versus heart uh decision
in my book
uh I hear exactly what the parish
council and residents are saying
um and yet we are driven by facts and
evidence and without drawing it out I'm
I'm struggling to find a material
planning reason to go against the
officer's recommendation because I think
we've we've questioned the officers
quite quite thoroughly on our points of
concern
and their replies have been persuasive I
think so I am minded to approve
are you prepared to make a proposal
councilor Harvey I would hate to steal
your thunder chairman thank you
councilor littlewood
yes
um
this is this is difficult
um I I I'm living myself in a rural
Parish I understand the impact of
vehicles have on on the local area and a
small incremental increase in traffic
can
feel very very imposing
but I think without repeating what's
already been said we have to bear
only in mind the facts and the evidence
has been put before us and whereas
um I feel for the local
population and their their anxiety over
this expansion it does create a an
improvement to the local economy
with to be honest what seems to me from
the evidence provided a relatively small
harm to the the area and so I too am
minded to support the officers
proposal councilor homes would you like
to speak
I think everyone else has has pretty
much raised the main points here as as
Council Harvey said very much head head
versus Hearts um I think everyone
appreciates that there are definitely
issues but I don't think anything
properly grounded to to pick apart to to
make a a refusalem unfortunately
okay in in which case
um what I would like to say is that um I
I too am concerned that um there have
been a lot of objections to this
um people are concerned about the impact
of the incremental expansion of the
industrial estate and particularly the
hgvs on this route but that I feel we
need to be
um making a decision based on the
evidence placed in front of us about the
number of vehicle movements and also
about the accident statistics
and the fact that various conditions can
be attached to ensure pretty much ensure
the routing of those Vehicles so I'm
prepared to make a proposal that
we go forward with the officer's
recommendation and that this application
be granted subject to the conditions
laid out in the report so that is my
proposal and I'm going to look for a
second for that proposal please
who's going to be prepared to suck in
that proposal
counselor Perry is it
councilor homes is prepared to Second it
in which case I'd like to move to a vote
on the matter
so all those in favor of that proposal
please
that's unanimous I think is it yes
thank you very much members
so in conclusion then
um
in respect of
just getting them right uh
2201653 that's uh
field rear of napton nurseries Tom Lowe
Road Stockton the committee is
um
has made a decision to accept the
recommendation of the officers and Grant
permission subject to the conditions
laid out in the report thank you very
much members
thank you very much councilor Keithley
uh we'll now move on then to item four
which is application 23 slash zero one
three seven seven slash ful Stables rear
of copperfield's Broad Lane Tamworth in
Arden solid Hull are presenting officer
israanaki when you're ready take it away
thank you chairman the application size
is within the settlement would end as
denoted by the black dot on the map
I'm sorry
copper The Stables are to the rear of
Copperfield which is Vin settlement it
would end
whilst outside the boob is read
alongside existing development and not
of an isolated structure
The Proposal would utilize the existing
gated access to rear from the b4101
broad Lane
minor alterations to the Landscaping
immediately adjoining the building are
proposed as showing above
and the proposals are for the change of
use of a stable building to Holiday
Cottage
the plans and Friends of you show the
building as existing and aside from the
front elevation would remain as
is
um the only as I said the only
alterations are to the front elevation
um this is looking up towards the site
from Broad Lane
you have the garage of Mulberry House to
the right hand side
this is looking back towards the
existing stable and The Paddock within
it
this is stable and looking back towards
the share boundary to the neighboring
property Copperfield
this is looking down the Access Lane
back towards Broad Lane Mulberry House
is viewable to the left hand side
Mulberry House is the applicant's own
property and they own
the access track and The Paddock where
the Stables are
just for clarification
and the existing access onto Broad Lane
is shown here which is to be retained
the officer recommendation is to Grant
the application subject to conditions
that are set out within the officer
report
thank you chairman
thanks very much Ron uh we have two
registered speakers first being
councilor Saunders of tanworth Parish
Council
good evening
yeah once you're once you've had a seat
um so you've got three minutes uh I'll
give you a 30 second warning and
otherwise when you're ready take it away
the key issue in this
with this application
are you hearing me I get an echo sound
does that matter
okay yeah
anyway as the officers report points out
is Greenbelt is this acceptable in the
green belt
and he rightly points out that there is
a provision for the ReUse of buildings
provided that the buildings are or
permanent and substantial construction
and here we're referring to Stables
in our view there are two issues first
is the issue of reuse that rather
implies that a building has been around
for a long time
and is no longer needed for its purpose
um and it's sensible to make use of it
in another use
but this building was only put up three
years ago
and as far as one of the objecting
neighbors is concerned has never been
used as a riding stable
and he draws the obvious inference from
that
and the second issue is this of
substantial Construction
um an 83 year old member of our planning
committee climbed the gate and had a
look and his report is that it is a
timber frame building with wooden
cladding as you would expect for stable
building
so it requires substantial I would say
work to make this into a habitable
dwelling subject of building regulations
there have been a proposal for a new
holiday let without Stables being there
the obvious answer would have been a
refusal so the only reason we're letting
this go through is because of the
existing Stables which were not used
a lot of other points you'd like to make
firstly is there a need or demand for
Holiday lets in tanworth I'm not aware
of any that exist
there's only one bed and breakfast in
the area there really isn't much to
visit
so is this going to find a demand or are
we going to be faced in three or four
years time by the applicant saying I
can't find we can't make a use of this
can we relax the condition
and our other concern is that this seems
if you permit this application seems to
be a route for other people in the area
where property values are incredibly
High to do just what this has done get
permission for Stables which you can do
in the green belt and then after a
suitable lapse of time
um ask make it into a holiday let then
and after a further lapse of time ask
for make it permanent with the holiday
that restriction lifted
and one last comment it is I know there
are no restrictions in the proposed
conditions about limiting future
extensions to this
I'm not sure where the permitted
development rights apply to Holiday
let's I suspect they do
thank you chairman
thank you very much councilor just
within your time members do we have any
questions for our Parish Council
councilor Hench Serafin
uh good evening
counselor
can you um
reaffirm oh sorry yeah yeah that's right
there's miles away there
um can you reaffirm that these stable
so-called Stables have never been used
I don't know really how they haven't no
doubt the case officer asked there's a
neighbor in their objections to this
says they haven't right okay thank you
councilor Keithley
uh yes uh councilor Saunders now it is
me talking the red buttons on
um I know that there was um the
application for the change of use of the
land to equestrian use and the erection
of those Stables Tamworth in Arden
Parish Council didn't object to that
what was the land before it changed to
equestrian use was it grazing land
do you remember I don't know I think
we've probably thought to ourselves this
is an acceptable use in the Greenbelt
Recreation
um and let it be
right okay that's fine thank you very
much
thank you any further questions no in
which case counselors thank you very
much for your contribution this evening
okay we'll come to our last speaker now
who is Miranda Rogers agent for the
applicant
good evening
uh so you also have three minutes
and uh you normally know the drill it's
the button on the right hand side to uh
turn the light on
there you go and uh when you're ready
take it away thank you
as you have heard this application
relates to the conversion of a vacant
stable building to a holiday Cottage
it's recommended for approval and has
been considered by your members because
there's an objection from the parish
council their original objection
referred to non-compliance with
Greenbelt policy and a lack of need for
a proposed holiday Cottage
your officer's report clearly sets out
the policies relevant to the
consideration of the application and
confirms full compliance I want to draw
your attention to two key policy areas
the principle of a holiday Cottage and
Greenbelt which also covers the parish
council's concerns
so looking first at principal core
strategy policy as10s supports
small-scale tourism visitor
accommodation in all parts of the
district particularly where proposals
would provide for local employment and
support rural services
the same approach is taken by policy
cs24 which further notes that wherever
possible tourist facilities should be
located in existing or replacement
buildings there are no relevant policies
in the Tamworth neighborhood plan and no
requirement in any document that
proposals must meet an identified need
in line with these policies The Proposal
is for a small scale it's creating one
two-bedroomed holiday Cottage through
conversion of inexisting stable
the development will generate some
employment associated with cleaning and
maintenance and will support local rules
for services including the railway
station and the public house that are
within 200 meters of the site
in respect of the green belt the core
strategy confirms that proposals which
occurred with national planning policy
will be acceptable
National policy states the ReUse of
buildings provided they are of permanent
and substantial construction is not in
appropriate development provided they
preserve openness and do not conflict
with the purposes of including land
within it there is no requirement to
consider the age of the buildings or
their previous use
the building in question was completed
in 2019 and is of permanent and
substantial construction the only
changes required to facilitate
conversion are alterations to one
elevation to increase natural light to
the proposed habitable rooms very minor
changes are proposed to surfacing
materials in the vicinity of the
building but taken together the proposal
will preserve openness and does not
encroach into the countryside the
cartilage remaining as approved for the
original stable permission
overall a proposal Accords to the
development plan and there are no
material considerations which indicate
an alternative view should be taken
you will probably ask whether there were
any third-party objections to the
proposal there were four from local
residents an addition to the matters
already discussed there were two key
concerns the first was highway safety
The Proposal uses existing access which
was granted permission in 2019 and there
are no objections from County highways
and the second is neighbor immunity with
particular reference to security and
Noise
the use as a holiday Cottage is no
different to any other residential use
and given the largely residential nature
of the area will not cause undue concern
in line with the office recommendation I
would ask that you grant planning
permission for the proposed development
thank you thank you very much just just
on time thank you members do we have any
questions for agent for the applicant
Council Harvey
Mr Rogers can you confirm that this
premise has been used as a stable or not
I am told by the applicant that it was
indeed used for stable purposes
okay
any further cascately
yes thank you very much a couple of
questions
um we heard from the parish council that
they have concerns about this
development in Greenbelt and you've
referred to one of the uh the policies
in respect of the um
the development small-scale tourism and
such like
um in respect of the national planning
policy framework and paragraph 150 and
my understanding is that preserving the
green belt and protecting urban sprawl
is really important and the judgment
about the visual openness of the area is
important as well I'm sure you know
about this because you're an expert in
this area
um what I'm concerned about is lighting
and residential use and bins and Gardens
and cars and sheds and stuff like that
can you explain how
this development preserves the visual
openness in respect of the Greenbelt
policy of the national planning policy
framework I think you have to compare
what's been approved to what's being
proposed so what's been approved is a
stable building with a muck Heap and
people coming and going and cars
visiting and horseboxes visiting which
are all quite active activities and a
building what we're proposing is the
same building no bigger the same drive
the same fences around this
um there will be a bin but there would
be a bin of sorts with stabling uh
there's a small amount of amenity
grassland which is shown on the plans
within the fence that's already been
approved by the previous application for
the Staples we're not talking about
residential paraphernalia that you would
have with a dwelling which would include
children's play equipment somewhere to
hang out your washing lots of manicured
Lawns and flower beds we're talking
about something a lot more rural than
that holiday Cottages don't need the
same level of paraphernalia which is why
they are deemed an appropriate use in
the green belt by your policies whereas
permanent residential is not I don't
think that the proposal will have any
greater impact on openness than the
lawful
stable use
okay well thank you for that answer I
think we could probably understand
however the concerns of the parish
council that you see a sequence of
events here where you have Agricultural
and presumably that was agricultural
land before it changed to equestrian
land that'd be right I'm told it was a
pattern the nature of product use I
couldn't comment
s amazing or something similar sorry
um turns I'm just explaining that that
we can understand the concerns of the
parish council
that that we we have one minute we have
some grazing then we have equestrian use
then we have a stable and there's
uncertainty about the use of the stable
so I think then it becomes a holiday and
then potentially it becomes all the
paraphernalia of a full-time residential
property if there isn't a need for a
holiday so my question really is about
how that affects the visual openness but
I think you've answered that question in
respect to the holiday letter so thank
you if I could add this was genuinely
required as a stable at the point that
the application was made made for a
stable and it was applied for by the
owner of norbury houses you've been told
unfortunately it was for his wife he's
separated from his wife and the stable
is no longer required
so he's looking for an alternative use
your policy is very much support the
ReUse of rural buildings rather than
leaving them vacant so that's exactly
what he's doing and your policies also
support
the local services and facilities and
that's what this development will do it
would allow additional support for those
important services like the rural train
station like the rural pubs
thank you very much any further
questions in which case I think you're
free to go thank you very much
okay we don't believe we have any
further speakers registered in which
case it's point of clarification from
our offices councilor homes first
um I was quite surprised when they said
that
that no consideration should be made to
the age of the building prior I I I I I
I was under the thought that before
there would have to be some period of
time between construction of a building
to then
renovation to another use it do is is
that not for consideration
Frankie counselor
um we did initially raise concern in
regards to as10 k
um which is
um the conversion of a building for
business purpose
um subject to it being there for 10
years
um we raise disability agents who
obviously came back and we spent some
time with our
policy planners to understand
in terms of the principle which part we
um looking at in terms of our assessment
and they came back and said okay is of
relevance but actually
we are looking at
um
as10 s which is the tourism and Leisure
and not okay
and just to clarify if you don't mind
um as10s doesn't require that the
building is in place for any amount of
time it just states that small-scale
tourism visitor accommodation and
leisure-based uses including Sport and
Recreation will be supported in
principle particularly those that would
have to provide local employment and
support rural services so this is not
that test that there is in as10k which
requires a building to be there for 10
years
yeah so so would that test and be
required so if you're going for a full
permanent building for a poem but but
because it's a holiday that it doesn't
require that
we would be assessing under different
parts of as10 if it was to be an
unrestricted dwelling
um it's Parts B to J set out the
residential K is under business and then
s which is what we're looking for here
is tourism Leisure because that's the
the relevant part of as10 in respect of
holiday let's thank you
put any further points qualification
Castle Harvey
um
are there any ways in which we could
condition this application such that it
could not be converted from a holiday
let into a dwelling
or is that not technically possible
thank you councilor
um we have put the standards condition
for highly restriction on the
application so
that restricts if if planning was
granted tonight that they can only use
it for highly that
obviously if they started using it for
residential that's obviously a breach of
condition
if then the line they were looking to
um
change the nature of that application to
residential they would need to submit a
new application which again we would
assess in line with relevant policies
and come to an a an assessment in that
respect but there is a restriction in
its use under this application uh if
permission forthcoming
so I take it the answer to that question
then is no you can't but you'd have to
deal with another application if that
were to be submitted at a later date
the answer is we would attach a
condition so condition four of the
agenda if I read you the word of the
condition that we would attach so it
would be something along the lines of
the development hereby permitted shall
only be used for Holiday accommodation
purposes and not for any other
residential use falling within class C3
which is dwellings of the use classes
order or any statutory instrument
revoking or reenacting that order with
or without modification for the
avoidance of Doubt any residential use
includes a person's or person's main
residence or a permanent residential
unit of accommodation so that would mean
any occupiers could only be holiday
visitors and if they wanted to
um occupy as a primary dwelling they
would have to come in to remove that
condition and we would then assess it
against
the the relevant parts of as10
very much councilor Keith you next
I think my question really is about this
issue of protecting the green belt
and paragraph 150 of the national
planning policy framework could the case
officer just help me understand how much
of the equestrian land is going to be
converted into sort of residential land
around the development please first
um I've just popped up the block plan
and the block plan is relevant because
that was the approved block plan for the
previous
development for the stabling
you can see the stable block
um here
and the driveway and there's a sort of
boundary line here
so
in terms of the split between the
paddock and the sort of land associated
with the stabling
um that would remain as approved from
the previous application to what is now
so there won't be any further
encroachment into the approved pallet
land for that horse
so if you look at this map compared to
um
this one this is the
um boundary fencing that I'm talking
about
um as part of
um this block plan so it goes along the
edge
so in terms of encroachment of the
paddock there is no encroachment
um and on the additional note in terms
of green belt obviously is set out
within the report
but
as part of my assessment I was very keen
um that what is on the site as present
even though it's converting to a holiday
let
that as much as the landscape and the
setting of that stable block is
retained as much as possible in respect
of the structure they initially proposed
quite an extensive glazed elevation
which I deemed to be too much in terms
of
visual harm and the access driveway was
meant to be block Paving
and I deemed that two suburban and too
fixed in terms of landscaping and to
retain the sort of gravel grass Crete
appearance that's there at the moment
um and yeah there's no encroachment from
what is there now and what's proposed
okay thank you for that so what you're
saying is all that land is equestrian
still subject to the applicant wanting
to change it to something some other use
in the future like residential use or
something like that which they're
entitled to do I understand could you
just help me understand this issue of
the nppf paragraph 150 and the
protection of the greenvelt to protect
um
Villages and such like from urban sprawl
back development stuff like that which
allows houses to be built in the
background
um I know it's an issue of judgment
there are some lighting issues in
respect of this as well because the
original stable I understand had very
low level lighting so what I'm Keen to
understand is how does the visual
openness of the green belt how does it
continue to be protected with this
proposal what's happening with lighting
for example in respect of what's there
now with the stable I guess very very
limited lighting or suddenly you're
going to get people in and out and
they're going to be a lot of lights
presumably because we've just shown a
picture of two bedrooms living room
kitchen everything else that goes with
it plus a car park
so can you help me understand your
judgment in terms of its impact on the
green belt
so twofold obviously I mentioned the
amendments to the elevational treatment
the initial proposals were for extensive
amount of glazing which
you sort of LED on there in terms of
you know if you have all these lights on
within the building extensive out of
glazing it becomes sort of a light box
to
the outside so I got the agent to amend
it to retain as much of that structure
as possible
I've also looked to ensure that if
permission was forthcoming that we
condition
um Lighting in respect of external
lighting to be as minimal as possible in
terms of
um
you know the existing stable may have
um floodlight not floodlights but you
know exterior lights to you know if
you're working late you can you know
have some light but we would be looking
to strictly control the amount of
lighting and the level of lighting on
that
site if permission was forthcoming
that's fine thanks so much
thank you any further points of
clarification
no in which case we moved to the debate
who would like to start counselor Harvey
I'm quite happy to lead off this seems
to me to be a straightforward case I
don't have any problems I happen to live
in a village in South Warwickshire which
is a very close to the Cotswolds
in my Hamlet there are at least three
um
similar holiday let's plus B and B's the
implications for traffic are negligible
you hardly noticed people I can't see
that in this location there will be any
particular significant impact I think
the officers have assessed the the
application uh in the way I with the
furnace I would expect and they come to
a conclusion I am more than happy to
propose that we accept the
recommendation
thank you very much councilor Harvey
anyone else like to contribute councilor
Keithley yeah thank you
um well I think I've tested my concerns
with the case officer in respect of the
development I'm con I was concerned
about the objection from the parish
council
um we can't look to the future but
people are you know quite entitled to
um develop their properties in
accordance with our policies and this
particular application I would agree
with councilor Harvey I can't see
particular problem with it if we can
control the light
and the design of the prop the holiday
letters more sensitive now we've taken
away some of the glazing
um I'm happy to I'm minded to uh to go
with the officer's recommendation thank
you very much
um just for clarification of that
proposal and second that I got there or
is it just stating opinions so far I I
was proposing everything thank you
I'm happy it's a second that was my
understanding just for clarity thank you
I believe I saw Castle hence seraphin
looking to contribute
well I'd just like to thank the case
officer on his deliberation especially
on the long driveway to leave it as it
is I think that's important in the dream
belt area
so yes I can't see any reason to go
against this thank you thank you very
much any further contributions to the
debate I'm quite happy to agree with
what's been said in which case we can
move to a vote
um so the proposal is to Grant in line
with the officer's recommendations
and the update sheet uh kind of see all
those in favor
in which case committee resolves to
Grant application
23-01377 ful Staples rear of
copperfield's Broad Lane
Jolly Goods
okay we now move on to our next
application
which is item number five
uh an application
23-01141 ful 33 Cranwell Drive
wellsborne
our presenting officer is Victoria
Kempton and once she's situated uh to
present the item so you can take it away
good evening and thank you chair
so the application site is located
within the dove houses estate within
Wells born as identified by the black
dot on the map
this plan outlines a site in red which
is a strip of land running along the
side of the residential property between
the existing garden and of House Drive
the use would change from open immunity
land to prop to a private garden and
Landscaping details for the addition of
a boundary hedge have been provided to
support the change of use
this is the Landscaping plan showing the
development in more detail the existing
brick wall would be removed and the
garden boundary moved closer to the
highway
the main head is outlined in green on
the planet I've included a photo of the
species on the slide
at the request of the council's
landscape officer the Hedge has been
moved back from the highway Edge to
allow it to spread as it matures and in
the interim period a range of low-level
planting has been added for ground cover
these site photos show the land subject
to the application which has been
graveled over and lies immediately
adjacent to the pavement
the existing brick wall marks the extent
of the boundary of the extent of the
site
so the first photo shows the front of
the main home with the site to the right
you can also see how the land subjects
this application is on the inside of a
Bend limiting views to the north
the second photo shows the site in the
background and you can see how there are
multiple brick boundary walls which meet
the highway surrounding the site
um the brick brick wall boundary
immediately to the north of the site
also meets the highway Edge
along here oh sorry
along here
as set out in the officers report the
recommendation is to Grant the
application subject to conditions there
have been two updates as listed on the
update sheet and that concludes my
presentation thank you chairman
thank you very much Victoria uh we move
on to our first Speaker who's councilor
Anne Pryor wells-bourne Parish Council
good evening councilor is the button on
the right uh you have three minutes
I'll give you a 30 second warning
um before your time is up otherwise when
you're ready take it away okay thank you
the parish council strongly objects to
this application
on Monday this week I spent quite a lot
of time opening a new open space in the
village for the residents and it comes
as a bit of an irony that I'm coming
here tonight to talk about not in
closing space and losing open space
again in the village
the immunity land is generally owned by
Warwickshire County Council on the dove
house estate and as it abuts the highway
the strip of land running alongside the
boundary of the property a cause
actually with the planning conditions
laid down by Stratford District Council
itself during the planning application
for the development of the dove house
estate
the amenity strips of land of which
there are 20 more across the estate
um create an open green appearance and
add to the pleasant aspect of the
development if every house were allowed
to land grab in this manner and hedge
them off changing the boundaries of
their properties to swallow up the soft
Landscaping the estate would change
dramatically in appearance and feel
the planning application you had before
you is changed on a regular basis but
our objections remain the same
CS5 refers to the importance of
landscape and that any development must
mitigate damage to it the original
developers created this Landscaping our
residents now to be permitted to remove
it and consequently damage the landscape
of the whole development
cs7 makes clear the importance of Open
Spaces to the quality of life of
residents and the contribution they make
to attractive communities are we to lose
that too
are made neighborhood plans sought
advice from Arab about the provision of
Open Spaces in the village and after the
development of two recent developments
of ettington Park and the Loxley road
development there would still be a
deficit in the village of 0.78 hectares
of open space
Open Spaces are not just play areas and
Parks but also open Green Vistas in
housing developments
this development or this application may
appear minor to you and the planning
officer but in terms of the appearance
of this Pleasant development in the
village it is not
if you grant this application you could
open up a stream of similar applications
and the green development would cease to
be instead the amenity spaces of which I
said there are another 20 across the
development would be swallowed up
I I see that the planting has been
changed but the Hedge has been suggested
grows to a height of 4.5 meters and a
diameter of 4.5 meters and left to its
own devices would cover the whole area
I ask you not to Grant this application
and to support the original decision
taken when this development came to
planning that it should remain open and
green with immunity land for all to
enjoy
thank you very much councilor well
within your time members do we have any
questions for our Parish counselor
councilor Keithley
thank you councilor Pryor
um you've just said that um you wanted
to preserve the open Green Vistas I've
Just Seen A Photograph unless I'm
mistaken it looks like there's a big
brick wall and there's a sort of verge
alongside it I mean what what is it
about the open Green Vistas
in relation to this particular sliver of
land that you're trying to preserve only
to understand that
turn that off sorry
um some of the houses in the original
development were built with boundary
walls like that but having said that
the areas that aren't like that are very
much part of the development and give
the open aspect they actually soften the
hard landscaping and as I've said
already there are 20 other of these in
this development if all of those 20
disappear we will have a different
situation and we can only see this as
being a potential tsunami of development
across our our state
right thank you so so just to be clear
you are preserving you would wish to
preserve that big brick wall and the
little bit of verge rather than have
planting along the Verge side yes
because what you're doing which is what
you're doing or what is being suggested
by the planning officer is removing land
that is communal land to put into
somebody's garden and that's not
acceptable and it's not acceptable
across the rest of the estate either
okay thank you
thank you any further questions for our
Paris counselor
no in which case thank you very much for
your contribution
our next speaker is Robert Bayless the
applicant
good evening Mr bearness uh you've got
three minutes as well um I'll give you a
30 second warning before your time is up
otherwise when you're ready feel free to
take it away
um I'd just like to start out by saying
that land isn't communal I hope
accessory title for it
the parcel of land to the side of our
property number 33 cramwell Drive is
unadopted and has never been maintained
by the local Authority the plot would be
an area of unsightly scrub land if not
for the Goodwill of myself and previous
owners in keeping it Weed Free
the sites is currently laid out with a
featureless gravel surface and a 1.8
meter high brick wall forming the
current house boundary
due to the previous informal maintenance
agreements I applied for and have been
granted tiled to possession of the land
for its upkeep on a more formal basis
and seek to use their space as a small
extension to my garden area with
Improvement to Street Scene by the
introduction of a soft Landscaping
scheme after extensive consultations
with Stratford District Council by
myself and landscape architect a
suitable planting schedule has been
agreed to provide an attractive
ecological enhancement to Dove House
Drive transforming the current hard
featureless space into an area of
Interest along the public Highway the
planting schedule includes for the new
Hedgerow to be in set from the site
boundary to allow for its mature growth
width so as not to encroach on existing
public footpath there are already
numerous examples of high Hedges along
the footpaths of these pieces of land
around the estate and so what I've
proposed to do is in keeping with the
area in my view the landscape plan
proposed offers a visual enhancement to
the street and therefore is in keeping
with the original vision of the estate
the scheme has been welcomed by
immediate neighbors and Local District
councilor who have offered positive
support to the application before you
this evening
thank you for listening
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for our applicants
no don't believe so in which case thank
you very much for your contribution
thank you
now we've got no further speakers in
which case we move on to points of
clarification from our officers any
questions Parry
um I just like the officers to give some
clarity
um on an element in the report
um the war the war member is
councilor George coucher who's also the
planning portfolio holder
um and yet his comments are made as no
representation
yet it fulfills
um comments I would like some clarity
on no representation
particularly also when we've heard this
evening from the applicant that there is
support from the discount counselor and
I just would like clarification as to
whether
um
no representation normally means you're
not sure of one way or the other and I
and I just think
um
I just like some clarification on
what no representation in a report
therefore means
thank you
as he has not registered to speak
in the absence of councilor coucher
specifically setting out that he
supports the proposal I wouldn't go as
far to say that he does support I think
if he wants to support he needs to put
either no representations but then make
it clear within the body that he's
supporting so that no reps might have
been an error but in this case he's put
no reps and then he's been positive
towards the proposal but I wouldn't say
that was as far as support in this case
because his comment hasn't triggered it
to committee it's been the parish
council objection we haven't had to kind
of seek that clarification in terms of
whether he's definitively supporting and
like you say he hasn't registered to
speak this evening
to the officers just confirm that were
there to be 20 other applications
subsequently each one of those would be
dealt with on its merits
um uh absolutely so as you know each
application is assessed on its own
merits and this application has been
assessed with its own within its own
character area within the settlement
pattern and as referred to within the
settlement bound within the um officer's
report uh regard as being had to the
neighboring boundary treatments
um where are the boundaries in this part
of the road are but the highway
so each application would be assessed on
its own merits were the ones to come
forward
we've heard from the applicant that
there are other hedges in this
development
um I wondered if there's any photographs
on whether or not you could actually
help me by putting up the photograph of
the brick wall and The Verge again
because it's kind of flashed up and
before I could see it it sort of
disappeared
um oh right okay so that's the wall
That's proposed to come down and be
replaced by a hedge and have we got any
photographs of hedges in a similar
location alongside the footpath yes
oh I see there's a hedge further down on
the left is that it yes there's a page
there I'll show you another photo
um just bear with me
thank you Victoria really that's fine
cue any further what's clarification no
in which case we can move to the debate
we would like to start
because
well
I think from what it looks now to what's
been proposed would be far better
environmentally
um
I can't see anything to go against the
officer's recommendation on this thank
you
is that a proposal counselor
yes I'll prepare
for Keithley
yeah I would agree with councilor
hencher Serafin
um
I can see it being an improvement
the land is owned by the applicant he's
entitled to win prove that land if he
wishes
we've heard that other applications to
put hedges in instead of walls would be
subject to consideration on their own
merits so I'm happy to second
the proposal to go with the officer's
recommendation
thank you very much uh Hangouts with
Parry
thank you chair
as a former District councilor
um for the whole of wellsborn
um
I'm very very familiar with
numerous applications that have come
forward specifically on this estate to
change
the openness
um putting up different boundary
treatments and on each occasion there's
been enforcement
brought forward because it was very much
detailed in the development of the dove
house estate and there were certain
areas in this particular area there are
walls that are that are complement in
that part of the estate there are there
are walls so in in my view I totally
understand and sympathize the robust
objection from the parish council
because this estate has got a lot of
history to it and it's something that if
you've been involved as a counselor as I
have since 2014 I'm very very familiar
with the
um
idiosyncrasies shall we say of this
particular state
I understand the parish council's
concern because by removing that brick
wall and this particular area I know to
you all it looks as though it's tidying
it up but there is a principle at stake
and removing that brick wall
and creating a hedge in that particular
location where you've got brick walls on
the other side will change that
particular area
of the duff house estate and it is going
back to my particular knowledge of this
estate that I feel it would cause
um
there would be an impact to the
character of that particular estate and
therefore on this occasion I will be
going against the officer's
recommendation because of my prior
knowledge and involvement as a district
councilor for the whole of wellsborn
although I'm only now
um Wells or north and rural
thank you councilor was that a proposal
counter proposal or just a just the same
in a position at this point you have a
proposal and a seconder anyway so
we'll see how it falls but I just want
to raise my concerns on the basis of
personal knowledge and also
um in terms of the character of the area
thank you very much any further
contributions to the debate
again only just to ask the uh
just to confirm the case officers
concluded that the proposed change of
use and the Hedge would not harm the
character and appearance of the street
scene and the character of The Wider
area in accordance with cs9 cs20 that's
what's been stated in here unless I'm
misreading it that's what you said
recommendation basically
I don't believe we've got any further
contribution to the debate in which case
we have a proposal and a seconder to
Grant in lower the officers
recommendations
uh and the update sheet uh can I see all
those in favor
all opposed
one
in which case uh
committee resolves to Grant application
01141 ful
all right thank you very much everybody
uh we'll now move on then to our final
application of the evening which is item
seven
application 23
01939 c-o-u-t
and it is travel on Avon District
Council Elizabeth House Church Street
Stratford Haven
our presenting officer is Emma Booker
when you're in place feel free to take
it away
good evening thank you so the last time
on your agenda is um a prior approval
application for the change of use or the
conversion of the top floor of Elizabeth
house for use by King Edward VI school
which is located just across the street
um prior approval is not a planning
application per se it's a expedited
process the council has a limited time
period to determine these applications
um the level of information that we get
given is is minimal and as set out in
the report we can only consider certain
things I've assessed the application
against the permitted development
legislation I find that it's acceptable
and therefore I'm recommending that we
issue a decision of Prior approval not
required and they would be a condition
on that requiring them to implement it
in accordance with the
proposed floor plan drawing which you
can see there so minimal changes I don't
have any information related to external
changes to the building
these are what are proposed within the
prior approval itself
thank you chair and there was no updates
and yeah provided
thank you very much okay no speaks on
this item so we can move to points of
clarification uh any points of
clarification because littlewood
uh yes thank you Jim
when I saw this
and I saw science rooms
I Laboratories
I wondered what sort of science we're
talking about and what sort of
Laboratories by background I'm a chemist
so I immediately think of physical
sciences uh chemistry biology
physics
computer sites
computer science doesn't use
solvents the others do
now this is putting a hazardous Zone at
the top of the building and I would like
clarification about I mean clearly
health and safety regular and
regulations pertaining to storage of
those sorts of materials and use of
those sorts of materials will be
observed but where and on the second
floor would you be able to do that
that's my immediate concern now forgive
me if I'm I'm being obvious but it it is
it's just a a straightforward question
of a mixed use of this nature of a
single building
you have a comment that this application
only really deals with the principle of
the conversion I'd say that that sort of
thing would be covered by separate
legislation do you agree with that
yeah essentially health and safety isn't
a prior approval matter within
legislation so it's not something we can
consider but what I would say is it's a
school so you know in terms of pupil
safety they're going to be obligated to
treat those kind of substances in
appropriate way and on the proposed
floor plans there are a number of store
areas so you can assume that'll either
be stored safely in there or potentially
across the road at the school but that's
only a guess but like I say in having
regarded the legislation there's nothing
that we could kind of refuse on that
basis
thank you I'm happy with that probably
any further yes counselor can I just
understand the procedural process we're
going through that are we being required
to vote on anything or are we simply
being asked to note that the officer
states that no private approval is
required in this particular instance but
I'm just curious
we will require a vote we basically
ordinarily as you'll know probably for
applications don't need to go to
planning committee and that's because
it's just uh whether it complies with
the legislation or not so we're not
thinking about the interpretation of
planning policy so that's why they
normally don't come to planning
committee obviously the reason that this
one has is in the interest of
transparency it relates to this building
and a building owned by SDC so we
thought it was appropriate to bring it
to make sure that members agreed with
our approach we will be asking you to do
a vote in in the normal way so whether
you agree with the recommendation or you
don't but obviously again we're not
looking at planning policies that would
just be if you don't think it complies
with any of the legislation as set out
in the general permitted development
order
very good any further points
clarification
uh know in which case we can go on to
the debate um I'd like to start and
propose that we agree with the officer's
recommendation that uh prior approval is
not required and that is my proposal I
will be seeking a second can I second
seconded by councilor Harvey thank you
councilor Parry
uh thank you chair it's just really a
bit of a an observation whilst I'm very
happy to support this
um I think it's rather sad that
um
Stratford's very fortunate to have cares
it's probably
the one of the well certainly the I
think it's the best grammar school in
Warwickshire and yet the Town Council
um have submitted no representation I
think it's a very sad
um point that the Town Council
um
don't want don't have a view on the top
school one of the tops one of the top
two schools in Stratford
um and it's also perhaps unfortunate
that the world member hasn't commented
either
but I'm very happy to support and it
certainly gets the thumbs up from me
thank you councilor Parry uh are there
any further contributions to the debate
uh in which case
um proposal is to
agree with the officer's recommendations
can I see all those in favor please
which case Council resolves to agree
with your officer's recommendations for
application
23-01939
c-o-u-t Stratford on Avon District
Council Elizabeth House okay thank you
very much uh item eight urgent business
no urgent business in which case I
declare the meeting close thank you very
much